dès les premières minutes après la
destruction du boeing de la malaysian
airlines les deux parties au conflit
ukrainien s'accusaient mutuellement
d'avoir abattu l'avion civile tuant deux
cent quatre-vingt dix huit personnes au
pays bas ont présenté au public la pièce
maîtresse qui a permis au bureau
néerlandais de sécurité aérienne
d'arriver à ces conclusions
on a reconstitué le poste de pilotage et
une partie de la classe affaires du
boeing jb giustra directeur du bureau
néerlandais de sécurité aérienne déclaré
sans équivoque que c'est un missiles de
fabrication russe qui a détruit
l'appareil malaisien le missile de type
books a explosé à un mètre de cette
partie de l'avion décapitant
littéralement l'appareil on a retrouvé
des fragments du missile dans les débris
de l'avion et dans les corps de
certaines des victimes du côté russe
avant même la présentation du rapport
aux landais les fabricants de missiles
boucle la compagnie almaz en ti a
présenté un long exposé accusant les
forces ukrainienne via novikov le grand
patron de cette compagnie russe
déclarait que le type de missiles
utilisés ne fait plus partie de
l'arsenal russe mais que l'armée
ukrainienne en possède et que c'est de
son territoire qu'on a tiré
c'est là une des hypothèses étudiées
rejetée par l' enquête multinationale
piloté par les pays bas sans accuser
personne
l'enquète conclu que le bouc missiles
sol air a été tirée à partir du
territoire à l'est de l'ukraine aux
mains des rebelles pro russe un vrai
boom le premier ministre néerlandais
mark rutte et dont 186 citoyens ont péri
dans cet écrasement demandé à la russie
d'accepter les conclusions de l'enquêté
et des dés désormais à trouver les
coupables de cette tragédie
est ce que le premier ministre
néerlandais peut désormais non compter
sur la coopération des autorités russes
on verra bien en tout cas il est bon de
se rappeler qu'en juillet dernier à
l'onu au conseil de sécurité de l'onu la
russie a opposé son veto à la création
d'un tribunal international visant
justement à retracer les responsables de
cette tragédie
et c'est raymond st-pierre radio canada
à moscou